I
yeah
good afternoon everyone I'll welcome you
to this audit and risk meetings this
committee meeting this afternoon and
call for any any apologies I have two
counselor string and councelor Reed I
think that there's no other members
missing could I have a move that those
apology speaks councel guard on second
please the mayor B bell all those in
favor say I I against
carried welcome
miles thank you can you hear us all
right
you hear me right yes we we can we we
can hear you fine so we move on to item
two which which is the quarterly
treasury
report miles have you got anything to
add to your
report um well if you just want to give
me a few minutes because the world is
really changed considerably since I wrot
the report this report was especially
the commentary and how it applies
to the counil
because
scenes
PE oober after the report was written
and uh they actually reach Peaks that we
haven't seen since just before the
global financial crisis that was the
extent of the move up that we've
actually had uh and it was especially
pronounced in the two months probably
leading up to the end of the quarter was
due to a number of factors you know the
US debing the
infl yeah that would be useful
miles so on
October produced what we
call for
the the market
they the US
eony
consing the housing market and also and
what the markets took took as
meaning interestes anymore and they push
they started pushing the US Treasury on
down quite considerably ited
the2
it's after
they they inflation was slightly lower
than expected so they took
information was
the only thing it was theyed this for
the year October out
near
Andy
October
js5
and push as well
newal lower lower slightly lower def for
the quarter slight lower
Bond so we' the US here in two two
months
by5 and our yields have fallen not quite
to the same extent but still very
noticeably and um I
mean now we're about
460 years about
470 the shortterm r come down a bit the
90day rate is at 565 the 2E rate was at
at the E
Comal so
canes as as a of those moves in the US
now the thing happened is notice is that
Market at the of
DEC 83 32%
chance
30% that 32% it be 6% this ail next year
now
be5 by and
will by ail be at
5.75
Sealand
we just
to
questions e
no there's no question no
questions moving on moving on to the
report on the liquidity and
funding shows that you've got a very
good spread of maturities this is I
don't know what it your
theity
anding
policy compliance you are compant with
policy
uh policy control but also the liquidity
Rao liquidity ra is one that's imposed
by the local govern funding
agency
B just to ensure that he can Fund in the
event of
some
circumstan
so
keep
a in with law just before the end of the
just to make sure that we are okay with
that I mean
she the end of December
early early
January okay with the possibility of
um early janary with the possibility of
some very short uh tenured work uh this
side of Christmas but that's not a
guarantee but it could
be I
gement SL shows that you are above your
policy
comp
have
maximum just explaining that from an
interest management perspective what my
strategy here for you would
be lower term
rates that's unusual and the last time
we had it was just prior to the Global
Financial price it's normally an
indicator a precs to recession we did
have recession Reserve statistics the
numbers this year we didn't actually
have a recession recession
wasn't what it does is it reduces swap
rates swap rates we C de ones that start
in the future are actually lower than
ones that start
now for example we can do some forward
start swamps starting in say two or
years time about 4.4%
where the the equivalent swap rate is
about
47 so what we want to do is put when
rates level for these
below
so if we can get some what we call
forward start slots
4% we would to initiate and then
as
come the ear
Thea
one and ites really come back to what
the is the neutral rate for the ACR I
mean I think it's somewhere between
you were a little bit more optimistic
than you were thinking
weer yeah I was thinking a little bit
higher but but at the end of the day no
one
but if the if the swap rate gets to
below four then that gives us an
opportunity to lock in a rate that's
going to lower the council's cost of
funding and therefore lower the impact
on rates and that at the end of the day
is the more
important before we initiate the H so it
will give you higher levels of fix rate
coveres than where we are at the moment
it'll lower you cost of F and it'll
it'll give you more certainty of
interest
rates more certainly interest cost going
forward now on that same page it does
have your interest rate
projection now that one is actually
Fallen a little bit since because of the
Fallen interest
ratees that projection has fallen and
that the I've just updated that just
before and it had you falling down to
about your your rate falling down to
about
4.24% by June
2025 at the moment 4.7 I think that
actually might get lower I think that
projection will get lower as as TR
continue to fall and I think you'll get
closer to 4%
so that will happen when the reserve
seing ccle comes in um the cost of
Ft doesn't look B pretty at the moment I
mean it is the same as as a lot of other
councils and you're I mean some good
news there is that you've got a Flor in
front
us so you're
4.83% so um it's certainly it's not it's
not the lastest but it's certainly not
the highest the problem that one of the
problems that we two two problems here
highly think I might no
one not the newal
reserve borrowers and interestes going
negative and not not fix any debt US
Federal Reserve didn't pick it the banks
didn't pick it econom didn't pick it the
market didn't pick it we didn't pick it
um and this was just the something I'm
sure I've said it before this is just
the occurrence that happened because of
Co and the inflation effects of
it
EXA that your but your your steepness is
actually that the increas is more than
others because of the amount of De that
you off at these high interest rates so
that's just function of the that you
have levels
of a time as I you get some think now I
think
your maybe a little bit more than that
sh on the previous slide so
um that's the uh that's the report I
haven't taken too long are there any
questions on
that Michael has a question yeah Mars
you sent me the latest lgfa borrowing
rates uh earlier today and when I look
at it it tells me that the expected
average return over the or interest rate
over the next 5 months is 5.84 4
3 then the expected interest rate in the
sixth month which is May next year is
6.22 and then the expected interest
rates from June to October next year or
November next year is
5.75 just just got the last
the
but yeah this is the one that's come
today
yeah yeah so so for the next five months
it's 5.84
3 right and then in the month of May
next year it's
6.22 and then in the months from June to
November it's
5.75 now if you just to solve the
implied interest rates based on those
borrowing yields and that tells me which
coln are you looking at sorry the at the
short-term loans yeah borrowing yield
unrated councils oh yeah okay so three
months um so 5 months 5.84
3 yeah uh one year it's 5.83 so you can
actually solve backwards and so it means
in May next year at
6.22 and then in June to November next
year it's
5.75 and that just that just tells me
it's a
nonsense right because you can't you
can't have 5.8 jumped up for one month
to 6.22 and then immediately falls back
down to below
5.8 so there's something going wrong
with the lgfa book for them to be
offering rates like
that and so is it is it an
you looking atth CP rate
5.82 no so if you look at the 6mon
borrowing yield unrated councils
5.96 right so if I pay 5.84 3 for 5
months and I pay 5.96 for 6 months that
implies that in the sixth month I must
be paying
6.22 I Know It This starting to get
technical but that it's just a nonsense
that the rates would jump up that much
in one
month so there's something either wrong
with the rates or there's something
wrong with the book of
lgfa the 5 mon rate is
5843 yep the 6 month is
5.96 and then the one year is
5.83 5.83 so it's down s points yeah so
you can solve backwards to work out what
is the rate for the first 5 months what
is the rate for the sixth month and what
is the rate for months 7 to
12 what is the implied
rate yeah at that think it's aun of the
ined r start going down but but that
just tells me that there's going to be
opportun or there's expected to be
opportunities on the next six months for
us to lower our cost of borrowing yeah
yeah
at to you before it's actually giving
you the opportunity to have lower
interest rates over over the next six
months because we've got theed deal
curve at the moment
yep so that's so to me the question is
what processes do we need to put in
place to make sure that we capture those
opportunities should they they occur
because the the market is saying they
should
occur so um what we monitoring the rates
on a a daily weekly basis my trigger is
that some of these forward start swap
rates get below this
4% I'll have what I'm doing is I've
actually already got the
bank that um who who you transact swaps
with but if these rates do get below 4%
but i' like I'll look for counil
straight away which the most opport
to
I
to C fans and then ATT the council to
the LA
um to the she has the authority over the
treasury policy and I'm certainly happy
to share with the a risk committee if
you want me to run past that as well if
it's if it's your responsibility so I
think you can you can sure that I have
got that order the bank or what we call
it anyway if they get so we can
initiate well I guess my my question is
for the the council's management in
terms of with law a away how do we make
sure that we can respond on a timely
basis three Mr Cher I guess that's we're
relying on Miles I guess and uh his team
of experts to actually guide us in this
area I mean the count This this term of
council hasn't put in place the treasury
management
subcommittee which uh I think would
behoove it to do so so that for those
who are new the last term of council had
a treasury management subcommittee
comprised of
um um obviously Michael Miles and a
couple of elected members and Senior
Management uh to just be able to review
the interest rate environment any given
time and make decisions to respond to uh
difference and conditions or
advantageous circumstances as they arose
and reported back decisions they made to
the audit and risk committee and um it
may well um that this is not this is
beyond the orderin committee to set up a
subcommittee but it can recommend to the
full Council that a treasury management
subcommittee be instituted uh for the
balance of the current electoral
tomb my my question was more in terms of
with law AR if it happened tomorrow
do we have the right people in place to
make the decision because we haven't
delegated decision to
Miles through you Mr chairman the answer
is yes because uh I have delegated
authority to to move as we need to in
regard to um recommendations that may
come from Miles um and L obviously is
generally the the go-to person um she is
still available on a limited capacity um
but I would be the first port to call or
cab off the rank to deal with any um
treasury recommendation emanating from
M so I could send an email
to your Steve and la and if you want me
to copy any of the committee me I can do
that as
well through Mr and the be good miles I
think it would pay you to copy in the
chair of w risk Stuart and Michael
independent member yeah
yeah I'll let that discussion run on
this is this is extremely important for
Council debt a 1% movement in our
interest rates upwards costs an excess
of 500,000 to the council which in terms
of a 2% rate rise if we had to fund
another so it's it's so important that
we get this right and I've been
heartened by the discussion between
Michael and miles today that interest
rates are looking like declining because
I was scribbling if you saw my notes on
these Pages here of what extra cost it
would be as we borrow more money and I
can understand uh why we've suddenly
gone up people would say we hadn't
planned well but we borrowed nearly 20
million in the last we wild to fund all
our projects and that's all had to been
at the high rates because we haven't had
it in there so I
think and f that Mr chairman I think it
needs to be emphasized that the
borrowing the council undertook is in
line with a long-term plan yeah um and
was underpinning some essential projects
that we we now see have uh substantially
been completed whether it's Elizabeth
Street whether it's the Library store or
whether it's the new membrane plant for
the school water treatment or or indeed
matara
yeah yeah there was no employed
criticism in that no no just that was
just fact
yeah count coun I was just going to say
the the other question I had relates to
with the new government's announcement
that three Waters is
dead has anybody done any work as to
what that might mean for B boring um
because any new development was going to
be somebody else's problem not ours
Steve I believe that
you uh through Mr chairman look not a
not a great deal of work um at the
moment we know we've got about roughly
$10 million of Headroom in our um
borrowing
capacity uh that will enable us to do
some a couple of essential projects that
we need to need to tackle one of which
is the pipeline under the river uh and a
reservoir new Reservoir at for Gore um
but beyond that um it's fair to say
there are a lot of councils in New
Zealand are now steering down the barrel
of well what do we do um and this will
probably come to aead in your long-term
plan where we have to
forecast uh our our debt and Heather two
it was always on the basis that uh in
2025 the debt will a good portion the
three Waters debt would leave us for
another entity um and if we are to
believe what is being pronounced by the
new government that is not going to take
place although the new government I
understand is more around creation of
ccos and having balance sheet separation
that way uh if that occurs that will
give us more Headroom but we still have
the issue around uh the loss of the
revenues the loss of that business unit
to portion
overheads um and whether this government
has the same sympathy as the last in
terms of funding redress uh to uh so
that we know better off all remains a
moot point and I dare say um more
clarity will emerge in in the coming
weeks and months but uh a point that has
been I think uh struck Council very
deeply is how can we develop a long-term
plan when we know these Law changes are
are in the wind um and whatever we come
up with may not actually reflect reality
in the coming months so that's what
we're chering our minds at the moment
and uh there are
political um advoc he's currently
trained to try and see if if the
long-term plan can be put back a bit to
give Council some breathing space to
just try and figure out the landscape
over the next 12 months never mind the
next 10
years councilor
gu you probably I'm a bit shy of swaps
um I'd rather take the risk a bit more
and go short and then see the interest
rates drop um once you lock swaps on as
we saw in the last five six years we've
been paying above but now we're actually
winning on the swaps but um I'd like to
see a paper really on those swaps and
what the costs are and the margin costs
are to the banks that we pay on those
swaps to present to this committee
because I think it's very important to
understand the full cost of
swaps answer
that swaps at the right
time use property at the right time very
useful risk management tool because they
enable you to lock in these fors
especially especially in environment we'
at the moment to lock start swap rates
are below the current now at the moment
I could some swaps for in the future
starting or years time
years 4.4% now that's 1.1% below
the0
so at certain times they are very good
now what we've done with is
that
ience
it
um
also time as well
because swap the top of it so we've done
we've actually done counil the various
counil on this on this topic because
does get raised quite often
slops have a bad
connotation did rece public because of
what happened in 2008 especially with
the they
were
ATS I you've
got 3.22
2.9.5
3.34 they give you the
advantage um give you the ability to
take out uh an fix your interest cost
ones that areer than where we are
Nows
we
two like to get don't like fix on or the
other what we just want to do
councelor guine yeah I like the use of
the fixed rate bonds better than the
swaps I think there's a margin against
us
here if I can comment the most of the
time fixed rate bonds are the better
instrument there are a few times when
because of the Quirk of the market
uh you would actually take out a swap or
you better to swap the floating rate for
fixed rate uh but my experience
that's less than a third of the time the
rest of the time you you're better to
either be floating or fixed and get
certainty the big thing with fix is that
you can't do you can't do them out of a
long out of forward forward
start disadvantage to get
SWS is there any other comments on on
the treasury report in front of
us I
com got two
minutes we right with that okay
yes I actually got R up the other day by
after the election by the person one of
the senior guys at DIA who was
responsible putting in place theet
profile
asking certain
usil took view that july4 was going to
be the day
that there a lot of risk
manag risk managing Prof around agree it
didn't work what my colleague and I
think will happen is well not sure
happen but what seems to be talk about
the is what
Steve the CPE model control organization
trading
organization
but the B I'm
is what of guarante will provide
forance
sep the councils can't guarantee that
CCO and that's the only that's the way
counil and counil contr trading
organizations can get a lower interest
rate because they get the benefit of the
counil guarantee counil and therefore
counil because of stat ability to charge
General and special rates get a lot
higher credit standing in a cc which
would not have that ability so this is
to us this is the key
Point how this new entity will be funded
will it be as a stand Enterprise or will
it be as as a a separate entity but with
a council
guarantee
terms
B you deci you want to
guarantee
C
support guarantee it's going to cost
considerably more
tomorrow
be
AER but we don't know going
to
there we go uh just just on that those
two different routes number of questions
first um with the CCO guaranteed by uh
guaranteed by councils would that have
to be a council decision by each of the
councils involved in that CCO so will
they all have to agree to back that
ccs to guar ORS to leave it as a stand
alone National said that the new where
where under labor the new was going to
be
compuls be now they're saying will
beun and you don't have to join one of
these you don't have
toties
just you're to have the
weeres stronger won
join
yeah well our big players are denan and
Vaga andago was already indicated which
way they're going to go and I think
denan if they had a choice would be the
same so I think that'd be disastrous for
um a small rural Council like us but
that's just my political view um just
would that stand alone so even if they
would be able to charge their own rates
it would still be S considered a stand
alone like the interest rates would
still be
through the
roof well with the ability to charge
their own rates so if it was written
into legislation that they can charge
their own water rate for example would
they have that borrowing capacity would
they have that same borrowing capacity
as us or would they be no I don't think
I don't think water charge would carry
the same credit strength from from a
cred
a charge because the
charge as one of basic features the
ability toell
property it's easy toell house but you
can't PES or someone isn't
water their water rates and remember
their ability toell
property don't
charge
abity thank you for that that's hugely
insightful that's that's a yeah I mean
it couldn't have simplified anymore of
you can't sell pipes in the ground but
you can sell a hits above ground
yeah thank you miles we better leave it
there we've got to move on we've got
some other
meetings today
so thank thanks M uh could
uh could someone move that the that the
the recommendation that the report be
received Michael
or do I have a seconder John Council
guard on all those in favor say I I and
against carried uh do you want to word
something about a treasury management or
do we do that later dat you can
a recommendation to full Council if you
wish sorry can I interrupt I think I
asked about it at the previous Council
in the minutes and I'm I I remember
correctly Lun said it was going to be
part of the 19th December council
meeting if I remember
correctly I'm pretty sure I did ask
about and it was was um planned to to be
okay thank you for for that okay we'll
move we'll move on
to the age datas
report man management accountant isn't
with us so uh has anyone got any
comments or do you want to speak to this
report at all Steve
it's I will uh in to Mr look it's fairly
straightforward I mean you're always
looking for high percentages for your um
in terms of what's uh been paid in the
current portion so we have very low
percentages uh in the um 30 days and
greater uh so it's it's actually better
than what uh historically I've viewed in
the past so I'm very
comfortable yeah doesn't look to be
reading through the report to me it
doesn't look to be any problems with
with the payment of of
datas is anyone
else councilor guard on
first just on the um clean air loans I
notice um the applications have been put
on hold so basically that's been held
and the existing loans will just run
their time because of the changes to the
credit rating act yes yeah that's
correct Michael the the 5K that's more
than 90 days under notable
dettas is that likely to be embarrassing
for the
council that's
that's
rent on
land I don't think so Mr chair but I
don't know the actual property concern
so I can't give you a categoric answer
but it's being followed up so as chief
executive these things generally start
to arrive at your desk when things are
starting to Lo entrenched or difficult
to move and I haven't had that in my
Orbit to
date
anyone else got any comments or concerns
or questions about the
report it seems pretty pretty good to me
that we're we seem to be on track with
as the chief executive said so there's
nothing outstanding there would someone
like to move that the report be
received councilor PA fou second
please Michael
CH all those in favor say I and against
carried next next report is the three
Waters level of service report Aaron do
you want
to comment on this three Mr chair
um
just can take this report as as written
and I'm happy to answer any questions
does anyone have any questions for Aaron
or oh sorry may not so much as a a
question and I I I've said it um in this
forum before but just a very well done
to Aon and your team and Jason and your
team um for the Emergency Response it's
pretty impressive to have uh just was it
two two complaints um when the streets
were filled with water so I know that
you guys work tirelessly to to make sure
that was um pretty low so thank you very
much for for your guys
effort yeah Council mcf Paul mcf thank
you through the chat I was just going to
make a comment I say I think it's a very
good report I'd just like to make a
comment I actually got called up on the
flood day and I out on at the customer
house within 5 minutes so as a council
we were actually reacting quicker so I
think well
done is there any other comments or
questions on the report could I have a
move the report oh you're you're moving
move councel Richmond fail seconded
councelor
Gard all those in favor say I against
carried
health and safety report is the next
item on the
agenda Nikki have you got anything you
want to add to this
report
really pretty basic report this month so
um just happy to take any questions if
anything anybody has any concerns
over
Michael sorry sorry I don't have a
concern but I have a question as to what
would the evacuation times be if we
didn't tell everybody in advance when
the evacuation was going to take
place in what instance do you
mean was
that so so we we say when the next
evacuation date's going to be for the
trial
evacuations PS I can
assist um as a participant in the
evacuation I can assure you we didn't
know it was going to happen and we
didn't know we're being tested either uh
so I think the system works well this
was surprised to me in terms of the
dates being planned but um unless staff
put that on their desk in a sticky tape
somewhere I guarantee they'll probably
forget and they equal shop F me when the
sign goes off and you told me to get
out so I think in terms of let's just
that we record how long it did take on
that table so that we have a
recollection of what it was last time
it's probably just need to move the
table round mark because it was bit
clearer and just one comment here on
page it's 19 you've got MLT someone
reading this in the future might think
we're part of the matarial licing trust
perhaps we me to make that the
multiports
center no problem can be
confusing I have struck that with things
in the past where someone's written
something like that and it's got quite
confusing reading it years
later is there any other oh May B Bell
thank you Mr chair just a question um on
the evacuations the eastn South and
gallery um just wondering why that's a
new scheme wasn't my understanding that
we owned that building um as to why
we''ll be doing evacuations out of
there we've assisted with those
departments because we have staff in
them so our staff are sitting in those
departments so therefore we at that
point we help mandal with theirs at well
to do
theirs and just a typo there I'm assum M
it to be 2024 not 2023 on that bottom
Square correct
y are there any other questions or
comments on on this
report uh could I have a move at the
report we
received Mr CH Michael Chamberlain have
a second
please may B
bell all those in favor say I I against
carried
but next on the agenda is the rist poll
call on members additional contributions
so ask the interim chief executive just
to bring us up to date on this
please yes uh thanks Mr chairman look as
I said my report wasn't the news we
wanted before
Christmas um we had been getting signals
from Wellington that uh there may well
be call on funds of members this is a
scheme where I'm reminded or of my of of
those who have been married wedding BS
where it's um for better or worse uh and
this is in the worst category in terms
of if your contributions don't cover the
claims and together with the reinsurance
arrangements that can sometimes um make
this uh less painful than it than it is
um then you're left with the residual
liability that members have to pick up
uh the scheme is being wound down the
council has been a member uh since its
Inception of around 30 odd years ago um
and he can always be clever in hindsight
but I guess in reality this Council has
been a pretty lowrisk member uh we have
particular when it comes to Leaky
buildings uh construction methods are
more conserv ative and
conventional and most of the risk with
the Leaky buildings was uh to do with
the pre the uh 2004 building act but of
course there's u a 10year period in
which um owners can discover the got a
problem and then
litigate um and then get an outcome and
councils as you know are often the last
person inst standing and therefore a
fair Target so um we'll have to
obviously pay this and that clears up a
few years in the past but there may be
some other fund years where um there is
a an imbalance and there may well be
just as hinted l a future call on
members um so when the council does its
budgets for next year it may be prudent
um for this is something for the council
to actually consider is putting a
a provision aside for uh future
liabilities that that may uh need the
council to um to
meet Michael chair do we know if there's
any other court cases currently active
or planned that will have an impact on
this because it'll have to be a court
case for us to have a
liability
through you Mr chairman chairman I'm not
uh sure about court cases but I think
there are claims in the system that are
still being worked through and resolved
um that in turn May generate a court
case so um but if the committee wishes
to I could find out a bit more from the
scheme manager about where the various
years that have yet to been closed out
are and what exposure levels there are
to potential claims court
cases I'd recommend that we do that
because that's crucial to the provision
we put into the 10e plan yeah yeah we
need we need that Base information
otherwise we would be just checking a
number at the dartboard basically uh to
what
what what what what the size of the
provision would needed to be is there
any other comments or questions on this
report you got a question just a
question for the C through CEO through
the cheer there um I think I asked this
before done we actually made a claim we
made a claim have we we never actually
the
FED if there are no more questions or
comments on oh sorry May being B thank
you Mr chair um just on that then what
is the time frame for it being wrapped
up and do we still feel the need to be a
part of this so was there an option to
opt out
or three Mr we've opted out and the
scheme is being wound down but you still
uh accountable for the past years so
we're just working our way through
closing out yearby year um and to find
out just we just need to find out you
know what what is in the system that is
still alive and potentially could um
exceed the scheme's ability to actually
meet those
expenses
you note on the last page it's back in
we're dealing with 20 years 203 through
to 209 so could be still a few years to
come
yeah that's why Mr chair because those
years were high risk yeah uh the The
Leaky building syndrome was alive and
kicking pre 2005 uh and then was in 200
sorry yeah 2004 the building act change
and the the kind of construction methods
and use of untreated
Timber um and monolithic uh clanning was
push put to one side uh and therefore
most these claims actually emanate from
either pre2 2004 or the problem started
there and were discovered um in 2009
2010 even 2011 be and and therefore
triggered a claim which has to be either
worked through uh or it could
potentially be
a court case all the N Waterfront
departments so what year do we opt out
then what would this go up
to for you Mr chairman I think around
about
2018 off the top of my
head another 10 years worth of that
clock
that you yes I think most of the claims
uh under the the long stop what they
call a long stop rule with and most this
to do with leaky BS and under the long
stop rule basically it's 10 years after
the building was erected your claims got
to be lodged uh so most of the risk
arises around uh pre 2005 you we 10
years to that by the time you get to
2015 and 16 you should be out of the
woods
okay we've got a recommendation here
here can I have a a mover that that the
requirement the council pay the
additional contribution of $6,6 56 plus
GST by the 20th of September be
noted could I have a mover for that
councilor guine
seconded Michael
chamber all those in favor say I against
carried
right we're on to item six protoo
barriers and drinking water supplies
we've got a report from the three Waters
asset
manager do you want to speak to this
report through Mr chairman um we take
the report as read
um
yeah I guess the only thing I'd add to
it is that um the discussions with the
dral drilling contractor are progressing
reasonably well um we are talking to
them about some different um pipe sizes
and and some different options around
pipe
sizing
um to um reduce the the level of risk of
the
drilling um potentially um we
the drilling contractor saying that if
we went for four P four smaller diameter
pipes rather than the two bigger pipes
um it could could significantly reduce
the risk um and potentially be a similar
cost um sounds like they're happy to do
a design and and risk assessment and and
costing for some different pipe size
options um so that then the council will
be able to consider the um cost and risk
of of those options um and make a
decision um at a later date so um yeah
happy to take any
questions because the only way we really
can deal with this problem other than
putting in some treatment up at hbur
Avenue is get the water across the river
that's the short answer isn't it and we
got to have it done by December
2025 yeah that's correct
yeah councelor
McKenzie May what the if we went with
the smaller holes pipes Etc are they
still withdrawable and
flexible through Mr chairman uh and so
that that's another consideration that
we're talking to the driller about so
there's obviously an option to have a a
carrier pipe with a smaller pipe inside
it that would give you that
flexibility um but that then requires a
larger um hole to be drilled yeah um
my understanding is that the majority of
um drilling projects that they've done
um the clients opted not to install a
carrier pip um and um and I guess if if
there was an issue with if you did opt
out of the carrier plot um and just
installed a straight plot um and there
was an issue um there's potential
options to to line the inside of the
pipe um okay so so there there's that um
and that's one of the benefits of
looking at the uh four pipelines versus
two is that if you did have an issue
with one you've got some uh flexibility
um you've still got another pipe there
that that you can get um some water
through so thanks for that mat I think
in the past I probably did ask this
question of the two bigger pipes and I
think it was discussed that yes the
pipes can be still fixed for one of a
better
term yeah that that's correct and I
guess the other consideration around
that is um you know what is the
possibility of having an issue with a
pipe um once it's been installed um and
and with the the construction
materials um that that they now use um
that that possibility is probably pretty
low um um and and the other thing um is
is um generally uh the the procedures to
what they call dite um um the pipe um so
and that basically means you figure out
what the design pressure of the pipe is
and then go up another pipe class just
to give you that extra factor of safety
um so there's a lot of options there
around um managing risk thank you for
that
M Michael chamber is is the 3.6 to 4.1
million estimated cost a something that
we have known about and has built into
the current year plan or is this new
debt that we're going to suddenly have
to take
on Mr CH now this is uh planned in the
long-term plan uh we're either going to
build a bridge or a pipeline to River so
that's that's fact into de forecast
currently Council Gardon you have a
question just a question through the
chair for met um I
presume we were aiming for to a 9 in or
225 pipe what are we aiming for and for
two pipes is it 150 or
180 through the chair so lost me with
your um Imperial measurements
but the the original pipeline that was
going to go across the bridge was um uh
DN 315 315
mm um with the the shorter distance and
more direct alignment of the of the
drilling uh we can reduce that to a 280
mm pipe and still get the same capacity
um if we if we go for the same capacity
um with with the four pipe options we'd
be looking at a um a 225 mm
pipe um I guess on that the the original
design allowed for a lot of um future
proofing um So currently we need to get
about 34 l a second backwards and
forwards across the river um but the
capacity of that Original Part allowed
for 67 l a second um so there is further
options around um reducing that um
capacity if if if that was
um yeah if the council thought that was
a good idea it is a tricky one um with
with the the future proofing because
often you can um um spend a lot more
money or or take on more risk um
allowing for something that that never
actually gets used um but then on the on
the on the same side um you obviously um
want to do it once and make sure that
you have got enough future capacity so
um certainly needs um a bit more thought
before we confirm
it any other
questions
okay we got a recommendation that the
report be be received that the council
notes that t or expectation of achieving
compliance with the requirements for
pro Proto barriers in drinking water
supplies
so someone
move
okay if we file when our River
Crossing we are really in trouble here
and this is a risk we have cuz they're
going to come down and we will fail when
their times go quite badly what is their
plan if we fail or is
there through Mr chairman yeah I mean
there is that risk there um and
um I think we certainly there are
obviously alternative options and and
things um I think realistically we've
got a bit of time off our sleeve before
we need to progress looking at those
those options yet um and I I guess if we
got to say um the middle of next year
and we're concerned um then then we
might start needing to look at those um
but I think the other thing around
um uh managing the situation and the
risk is making sure that we have um
clear and regular communication with
tomato R I think um as long as they can
see that we're uh working as quickly as
possible towards a solution um and
um and um you know if we do um encounter
issues if if we communicate around those
and and
um make tomato aware RI aware of them
then then hopefully they'll they'll be
understanding of that um the other thing
I think to note here is is that we are
reasonably progressed around our um
plans to achieve um Proto compliance you
might have seen in the media over the
last few um weeks there's been a few
councils that aners as progressed as us
and are really quite concerned around
meeting that time frame um and and so I
guess um I wouldn't think that Tom
matter will be handing out um
enforcement notices to to every Council
that that can't meet that time frame if
they are working towards it as quickly
as
possible
I just just the question was I was
proposing if if if the river fails we've
really got to put it and we can't get a
bridge up in time the deadline is the
end of
25 you'd have to look seriously at UV
treatment on this side
Riv yeah that that would certainly be an
option yeah and um I mean it's yeah you
could look at um I guess doing a a minor
upgrade at HB to to get you through um
until you could to till you could get
your your pipeline across or or you you
can look at other options around getting
the pipeline across the river as
well yeah Mr T just uh I think M sums
are up very well either way it's
Hobson's choice because you've had this
long um process of trying to get a pipe
either under or over the river if we do
encounter problems and the risks were
presented to the council when it made
its decision mid year that okay there's
no things guaranteed both in terms of
pricing um and obviously
success uh but that's the course of
action we're pursuing if we go to a
bridge you've got most likely consenting
issues delays again there is a provision
called a an enforced um undertaking in
the legislation where you can undertake
to do to do the work required and the in
return tomato Ari will not prosecute you
under the ACT which does have as I said
to Matt in an email the other day I I
watering amounts of fines um and I would
think it would be incredibly harsh if
you had for example
geological barriers that prevented the
under River drilling that someone would
then seize upon you and and prosecute as
mat quite rightly pointed out we're well
Advanced and very proud of what we've
we've done today with our compliance of
protozoa infiltration we've got roughly
a third of the Town that's is not got
their protection and we're trying to use
all measures available to get that uh
pipeline connected and ensure the whole
of the gore Township is completely
protected um and when you look at what
infrastructure we have put in place um
we we're well up to kill I would have
thought compared to some others about
where they're at with uh all drinking
water standard compliance and ensuring
that PR can't get a foothold in your
supply so uh I think I'm really be com
comfortable as I said at the assets and
infrastructure committee meeting but
let's see how it um plays out and maybe
you know mid
year behold us to do a review and make
sure that we're still satisfied the
strategy and that we do believe the
outcome will be in accordance with our
expectations
are there any more questions on that so
we had do we have a second so do I have
a mover for the
report Council the guard on have a
second
please councelor Richard
mcf all those in favor say I I against
carried right that comes to that brings
us to the end of of the public side of
the meeting for the audit risk committee